was auf in fünf jahren sind wir schon so
weit haben dann jungs aus der siebten
klasse eine wette wer mehr aus der
fünften klasse können etwas glaubt netz
bekommen beim neuen video ja im heutigen
video also das ist folgendermaßen
passiert ich habe euch mal wieder auf
snapshot gefragt wenn ihr mich nicht bei
snap shot geld habt dann macht es auf
jeden fall mal extreme doppelte und
nochmal doppelt dazwischen ein punkt um
die nehmen könnte
naja egal auf jeden fall habe ich bei
snapshot gefragt jo ich brauche jetzt
eure hilfe
ich brauche eure stories ich brauche
eure geschichten
ich brauche eure history moment das
heißt geschichte mit rad aufgefallen
dass geschichte im englischen history
heißt und geschichten stories das wäre
also praktisch dann genauso als wird
bett im englischen bath heißen und
betten irgendwas anderes
wir machen einfach mal weiter ich habe
euch aufgefordert schickt mir einfach
mal eure kassen stories wo er irgendwie
geklappt hat und sehr sehr viele mädchen
von euch haben wir das auch wirklich
geschrieben und ich habe mich zum teil
echt kaputtgelacht also da kam recht
witzige sachen und da wollte ich heute
einfach mal mit euch darauf eingehen ich
zeige euch das mal
und ja es geht halt um so die krassesten
körbe von meinen zuschauern gegenüber
jungs ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
wie das bei euch an kommen wird ich
würde sagen wenn er bock auf mehr hat
auch eine zweite volk oder so dann lasst
einfach mal daumen nach oben da dann
würde ich sagen bei 10.000 like sooo
also sagen wir 12.000 likes kommt dann
die zweite folge bin ich gespannt ist
eure sache ich will gar nicht lang
lagern wir fangen sofort bei an let's go
und zwar mit diesem chat verlauf vom
28.08 2013
da hatte nämlich irgend eine x-beliebige
person die ich auch überhaupt nicht
kenne einfach einen youtube link
gesendet an den freund denkmal und
geschrieben leid mal mit allen accounts
betören zurückkam einfach nein
sport ist es einfach so heftig nicht
stellt euch mal vor
das fragt irgendwie und ist einfach nein
ich hab das gefragt
ich soll das gewesen sein das heißt die
likes auf meinen videos früher waren wir
keine echten leid das nehmen wir messen
wieder raus der spaß sollte auf jeden
fall habe ich das zugeschickt bekommen
vom guten freund von mir und da habe ich
gedacht das wusste auch einfach mit
reihenweise denkt sie schreibt über
meine freunde an jo lag bei bitte alle
das video mit allen von euren account
das mache ich natürlich nicht weil sonst
müsste ich schon mittlerweile ganz schön
viele freunde haben weil ich meinen so
für 50.000 likes wie zum beispiel auf
diesem video drauf sind nach keine
ahnung 12 stunden da muss man ja schon
ziemlich viele freunde für haben am ende
kommt noch drei wirklich ausführliche
stories ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt
einfach mal weiter mit diesem screenshot
und zwar jo
hast du vielleicht mal lustig mit mir zu
treffen wenn ich sag einfach ist ja
nicht schlimm und sie schreibt dann ist
ja nicht schlimm der versteht also heißt
nein
und diese ihr das heißt nein als ich das
zum ersten mal gelesen habe habe ich mir
auch gedacht eher geil
hast du gut gelöst mach weiter so jaja
machen wir weiter
ich war wirklich auch zum teil manchmal
schockierend ich habe ja auch viele
jüngere zuschauer und was ihr mir da
geschrieben habt von wegen ja ich bin
jetzt zwölf und ich wurde gefragt ob
jemand mit mir freundschaft plus
anfangen kann
da dachte ich echt mädel du bist halt
solche sachen hab ich denn jetzt nicht
mehr eingenommen aber wir haben auch ein
weiteren screenshot und zwar ich bin 15
und habe vor ungefähr zwei wochen einem
20 jährigen kellner einen korb gegeben
hätte ernst was daran jetzt schlimm ich
mein sind doch nur fünf jahre
unterschied kann ich jetzt überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen kann das e mail von
euch verstehen
also ich mein mann ist doch kellner um
mädchen anzusprechen nicht was also das
finde ich auch nicht gut
nur was ich dazu auch eventuell zur
verteidigung des kellners sagen muss es
gibt ja heute so viele mädchen wo man
denkt body ist schon 18
bodies schon 20 und dann bekommt man
irgendwie raus dass die erst 15 sind wo
man sich so denkt hey wie geht da ja
egal ich würde sagen wir kommen jetzt zu
den krassen stories bei der hier habe
ich mir wirklich gedacht was ein [ __ ]
auf jeden fall schreibt anonymen sag ich
jetzt einfach mal also ich bin halt als
14 und hatte jetzt eine richtige
beziehung aber das fand ich schon heftig
genug und hoffe dass es nicht mehr
schlimmer kommen kann also eigentlich
dachte ich dass wir eine tolle beziehung
führen aber nach sechs monaten hat
schluss gemacht und ich habe mich halt
gefragt warum naja dann meint er halt
dass es ist weil ich keinen sex mit ihm
haben möchte er war 16 dann habe ich ihm
gesagt dass ich 14 zu jung findet kann
ich komplett verstehen mit 14 ist es
echt so sollte man sich gut durch den
kopf gehen lassen
wir haben da noch diskutiert und ich
habe mich dann halt überreden lassen
möchte die beziehung retten wollte so
zwei wochen später haben wir das halt so
gemacht und es war echt schön nur sich
dann halt nicht mehr gemeldet und dann
eine woche später kabel nachricht per
whatsapp danke web habt die wette
gewonnen und ich dachte mir nur so hey
und hab dann seinen besten freund
geschrieben was er damit meinen könnte
ja und der hat mir dann erzählt dass ein
anderer kumpel mit ihm dem wetter hat
wer am schnellsten welcher aus meinem
jahrgang knallen kann
ich war aber nicht die einzige wurden
noch mehrere verarscht aber naja das
fand ich schon ganz schön heftig und ich
bin auch ziemlich ausgelastet aber mit
so einem untermenschen muss ich mich
abheben ja da hast du recht wo ich mir
geradezu denke mit 14 ist man in der
achten klasse ich stelle mir gerade vor
so jungs aus der zehnten klasse haben
eine wette wer mehr aus der achten
klasse knallen kann euer herz was auf in
fünf jahren sind wir schon soweit
behandeln jungs aus der siebten klasse
die wette wer mehr aus der fünften
klasse knallen können und in zehn jahren
haben dann leute aus der vierten klasse
in die wette wer mehr aus der zweiten
klasse knallen können
nein spaß komplett gestört okay jetzt
können wir zu einer weiteren richtig
witzig sorry das ist echt richtig geil
und zwar anonym schreibt ich hab mal mit
einem in einer disco getanzt und der war
schon recht betrunken und hat sich
irgendwie immer mehr an mir kleben
bis ein teil hat wurde und er hat mich
immer gefragt gerber pudern ich wusste
auch eben nicht was das heißt so weiter
kurze info pudern oder pudern ist in
österreich ein vulgäre ausdrücke für pop
hin und nach 10.000 mal game apu dann
habe ich gefragt weil es jetzt
vorangehen und er ja bitte und ich habe
ihm dann meine puderdose in die hand
gedrückt und hab gesagt viel spaß und
bin gegangen richtig geil ehrlich
richtig geil so freunde haben sich was
einen ping vor lachen meine auch und zum
dank hat er mir die puderdose
nachgeworfen ehrlich hätte ich das
gesehen und mit bekomme ich hab mich
auch tot gelacht hat gut gemacht der wap
oder wirklich sagen und zuletzt auf
diese story und zwar das ist eher witzig
als mäßig war mit drei freunden und zwei
freunden draußen feiern eine freundin
von mir von einem typ mega heiß und hat
ihn angesprochen mit ihm getanzt
es ging halt so weiter dann hat er sich
mit ihr zu uns gesetzt und wir hatten
ein bisschen gesprochen was wir da aber
noch nicht wussten ist dass er schwul
war was ja auch nichts schlimmes ist
diese eine freundin fragt die nach
seiner nummer aber was er dann gesagt
hat war der hammer könnt ich bitte die
nummer von deinem freund haben mein
bester freund einer von den beiden jungs
aus schwul
er hat ihm die nummer gegeben und sie
sind immer noch ein paar das heißt er
hat also dein freund geklärt war seine
freundin gail ja leute total gestörte
geschichten ich bin wirklich fasziniert
was da draußen so bei euch in der welt
passiert schickt mir auf jeden fall bei
instagram da heißt ich alex wie einfach
mal kurz eingeblendet weitere krasse
stories zu wenn ihr bock hab halt auf
dem zweites video last einfach nach oben
bleibt bei 12.000 gibt's den zweiten
part ich bin mega gespannt schickte das
auf jeden fall bleibt natürlich anonym
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns übermorgen
beim ein video abonniere nicht vergessen
könnt ihr kostenlos machen ich wünsche
euch noch einen angenehmen tag und wir
sehen uns wie gesagt über meine haut
rein